bonjour tout le monde
[Musique]
parce que comme on était un peu dans le
truc on fait le même concept que
quelqu'un
bonjour
c'est déjà long aujourd'hui on a décidé
de faire des Lego en vidéo concept
jamais fait sur énormément alors ça nous
vient d'où ça vient du fait que vous
voyez ce qu'il y a là dans le fond ce
sont une seule et même pièce en fait
parce qu'il se il se réunissent par là
c'est le chemin de traverse d'Harry
Potter évidemment c'est bien précisé
parce que peut-être que tout le monde ne
connaît pas donc 5544 pièces non non
l'ensemble là des quatre qui se connecte
après the faisait ça le soir après le
boulot il y a mon avis
surtout lui ou je suis resté les faire
et on a vu après que amixem faisait des
Lego en vidéo et on s'est dit on a
peut-être des caméras pour ceux que ça
aurait pu intéresser et du coup Loïc
vas-y bien on fait ça moi j'ai fait
ouais et il a dit ça comme ça et après
du coup on s'est dit du coup ce serait
pas un plagiat d'amix oui mais après on
s'est dit est-ce que un peu Youtube
c'est pas un place tous les mêmes
concepts en reprenant des inspirations
d'idées des autres et ben si et ben oui
et en plus peut-être il y en a ils vont
amixem ah mais c'est mort j'aurais bien
aimé voir Fabien olicard faire ça donc
on a décidé d'appeler ce format on fait
les vidéos d'amixem exactement
aujourd'hui avec préau l'art alors
certains vont Harry Potter aussi alors
certains vont dire pourquoi Harry Potter
bah parce que j'aime bien donc c'est un
844 pièces sauf qu'il a une
particularité c'est qu'il est en deux
maisons séparées et du coup je me dis on
pourrait faire une maison chacun sa
maison chacun sa maison on voit qu'il va
le plus vite de chacun sa maison tu veux
faire du défi
le piment de l'Espelette du coup
qu'est-ce qu'il y a que c'est lui qui va
plus de coloc je ne sais pas bah il
garde le LEGO
[Musique]
je vois la page 6 j'ouvre au début
peut-être ou ouvre au début voilà voilà
et alors à la fin de chaque poche alors
quoi sac à la fin de chaque poche non il
te reste des pièces et des petites
pièces bonus en plus mais je te le dis
parce que quand tu sais pas la première
fois
j'ai oublié de mettre
des j'ai eu une sorte de pression depuis
qu'on a dit que le premier qui termine
et je trouve plus mes pièces en fait moi
j'ai déjà fait Harry Potter je crois que
c'est fini après si ça vous plaît on se
fera à faire des grosses grosses pièces
en vrai voilà hop là j'ai repéré la
voiture de Ghostbusters mon frérot ok
bah alors moi j'ai réussi ma première
étape c'est faux non c'est faux elle est
pas terminée retourne sur ta page et
regarde là
un petit marteau effectivement mais une
baguette magique vraiment elle a un
marteau
elle a un marteau elle est bricoleuse
elle a un petit marteau si vous voyez tu
m'as retours ah mais je connais c'est
Pauline en fait Pauline quand la vidéo
de ce mec Benjamin verreck
en vrai c'est pas très long 844 pièces
déjà seul alors à deux ça se trouve toi
tu vas avoir fini que moi j'ai encore
dessus quand t'imagines quand même que
amixem et son collègue ils ont fait des
trucs pendant 24 heures qu'on fasse ça
avant de se lancer dans un truc de 24
heures mais si vraiment il s'en battent
les reins de ce qu'on fait bah après je
continuerai à faire ce que je fais
c'est-à-dire je l'ai fait sur l'eau moi
la nuit
j'avais fait une nuit complète de Lego
c'est en fait ça t'occupe l'esprit c'est
trop bon tu es si tu es en phasage je
pense trop en ce moment
[Musique]
de ta tête tu te dis nanana
est-ce que tu as des tiques ou top de
endettiques ou top de langage
[Musique]
si longtemps il y avait tout le monde
utilisait un peu le même Tik Tok de
langage Tik Tok de langage de langage on
disait quoi c'était Fanny qui disait pas
mal bonjour
bonjour
de faire une navette spatiale en fait tu
es sûr que tu m'as donné Harry Potter
alors on en est où dans la progression
de l'auras hop à toi ça va vite
qu'est-ce qui s'était dit tu faisais une
école de cinéma
à l'époque il disait ça et comme ça
après je ferai des Lego sur YouTube
[Musique]
alors ça je le mets sur le côté pour le
moment mais je crois que j'ai capté
pourquoi j'arrive pas parce que tu ne
fais pas ce qu'il y a
pas mis au bon endroit
mais c'est là où moi aussi j'y arrivais
pas j'ai mais ah ouais le magasin de
bonbons il implique ça en fait
nous hier soir hier soir donc là on est
samedi matin parce que des tournages le
samedi matin hier soir nous sommes allés
à Bercy pour la pour s'asseoir sur les
marches
du nouvel album de Bigflo et Oli tu
connais quand j'y vais pour prendre mes
places on me dit ah mais en fait tu as
invité pour l'after tu vois mais c'est
stylé c'est gentil et tout et on me dit
ouais mais attends il faut que tu mettes
un autre bracelet parce que vous êtes
invité au before ça c'était marrant ça
par contre le before bah il y a une
story on peut la mettre là la story
voilà c'était le before ouais mais toi
ça c'est méga stylé moi pour l'instant
prêter à la page 8 je suis à la base du
19e
on connaît tous cette histoire de fabou
qui avait pris une photo ou signé un
autographe en ce pense faisant passer
personne
on peut faire une photo et puis ensuite
tu peux signer ça
moi je veux pas m'embrouiller avec les
gens je pense qu'il y en a encore qui ne
savent pas tu fais du spectacle je pense
ah ouais donc ils savent pas trop ce que
je fais sur scène en même temps pour moi
c'est deux endroits très différents on
fait des choses très différentes tu vois
ma vraie vie elle est sur scène donc là
en fait tout le reste c'est pas la vraie
vie bah c'est autre chose mais c'est mon
considère quand même que mon mon vrai
métier c'est quand même ce que je fais
depuis 12 ans c'est être sur scène enfin
alors là ce que tu fais c'est pas un
vrai métier constructeur de Lego je
pense pas qu'il y a un vrai mec si moi
je pense qu'il y en a qui font vraiment
ça qui font constructeur bah oui c'est
sûr alors intéressons-nous Lolo
maintenant c'est bizarre parfois si je
parle avec des gens bah non ça s'appelle
euh
moi ce que tu comptes déménager cette
année ça me fait très bizarre ça fait
très longtemps que tu peux avec
déménager tu es le mec que je connais
qui a le plus déménagé elle a
l'impression d'avoir raté un truc là ta
vie non mais là là ouais ça ouais je
sais pas du tout ce que c'est et quand
ta fenêtre elle peut être mise alors que
tu as pas fait ça encore j'ai trouvé ça
plus stylé la fenêtre
comment tu penses que ça se fabrique les
Lego fabriquer le la matière en
elle-même c'est du plastique mais je
pense que c'est de mettre en place plein
de trucs là pour eux c'est full
plastique quand tu penses bah de moins
en moins d'accord en chaud en fait il y
avait la léogo la Lego conne 2018 Lego
2022 mais c'était le 18 juin ouais ouais
moi je regarde ça quand je regarde les
kidnappes d'Apple mon pote je suis au
taquet et donc c'est c'est une de leurs
priorité il y a des alternatives pour
faire cette oui et j'ai pas retenu on
peut vraiment s'atta pas de temps
intéressé la Lego code en fait non mais
je trouvais ça bien en tout cas qui se
mette à imaginer des trucs mais j'en
doutais pas toute manière tu sais c'est
c'est les bonnes actions tu dis ouais
mais bon ça est-ce que nanana ouais mais
en attendant de le faire et donc j'en
doutais pas que pour le bien de
l'entreprise en elle-même ici ils
étaient obligés à un moment donné passer
par là donc c'est cool qu'il le fasse il
était fort est-ce que tu joues aussi
Fabien non en fait c'était trop tard
quand les Sims sont apparus moi j'étais
en plein dans la vie active j'ai pas
trop le Time pour ça je sortais plutôt
le soir tac tac machin toi tu étais en
fait tu faisais la vraie vie tandis que
nous on faisait une société dans la
vraie light ok ok parce que tous mes
potes justement ils étaient en cours à
l'époque moi j'ai commencé à travailler
ah ça y est j'ai mon premier autocollant
allez moi j'ai l'impression d'un truc
après je dis ça c'est peut-être parce
que je suis mentaliste pour le coup mais
je pense que c'est moi qui l'ai gardé
les Lego un petit peu me permettre toi
mais sache que ce n'est pas là et rien
ne sert de
son pied du mur rien ne sert de se
nourrir l'hiver il
[Musique]
qui qui veut reproduire la voix des gens
morts enfin vraiment littéralement c'est
simple Alexa veut reproduire la voix des
gens morts absolument d'accord ça
m'angoisse énormément ce que tu viens de
dire c'est à dire bah c'est à dire qu'à
partir d'un échantillon d'une seule
minute de voix d'une personne qui aurait
parlé à ton assistant Amazon ton
assistant vocal et ben en fait du coup
ton accès elle peut parler avec cette
voix là en gros je vais chez quelqu'un
je dis quelque chose à Alexa ouais ça
enregistre ma voix c'est ça et ensuite
la personne peut dire est-ce que tu
pourrais parler avec la voix de Loïc
exactement et Alexa va parler avec ma
voix voilà désolé pour le Alexa chez
vous si vous avez une Alexa ok Google
dis Siri comme ça on les a tous fait
on aurait dit le comme dans Jurassic
Park très bizarre
[Musique]
tu vois il me reste plein de petites
chites là
tu sais ce que c'est ça c'est un chose
qui pour Lego
non mais c'est très pratique c'est quand
tu dis ah j'ai mal mis la pièce tu as du
mal à la ressortir et tout clac clac et
là tu fais voilà d'accord
c'est assez satisfaisant tu avais pas
menti ah tu as vu le côté construction
ah j'aime bien ça dépend de ouf
le premier problème ça y est allez mon
premier salon
[Musique]
dans un vlog il me semble où j'avais
fait pour la blague en arrivant au
bureau je vais plus dire je vais plus
dire bonjour je veux dire bon
[Musique]
je dirais c'est pas mal c'est des choses
comme ça alors n'a pas pris non
bien pris comme s'il a pris spams donc
Pams à la place de pas mal donc on dit
quand quelque chose est pas mal on dit
ah mais ça c'est pas ça donc voilà
n'hésitez pas à le reprendre c'est pas
qu'est-ce que c'est ça ah c'est la porte
bien une poignée à la porte faudra pas
l'oublier mon petit bonhomme oh ça non
oh ça non ça non de Provence
département je dois faire un jeu de mots
là-dessus tu dois dire numéro de
département de Salon-de-Provence je sais
pas du tout 83 c'est moi 86 c'est la
Vienne
code postal quoi c'est 13 ah oui
d'accord ok maintenant c'est parce que
c'est je le voyais comme un département
mais c'est les Bouches-du-Rhône donc
mais du coup 83 c'est quoi oui c'est le
Var le 83 ah bah c'est une vidéo qui
nous apprend des choses
c'est comme quand tu fais un peu de
bricolage mais même du
[Musique]
exactement exactement
tu réussis à faire quelque chose et ça
progresse en plus donc tu vois la
progression était là et voilà bah moi
aujourd'hui j'ai construit une maison
quand même c'est ça
aujourd'hui non je ne crois pas non
excusez-moi mais je ne crois pas non je
demande pas de médaille mais un minimum
de respect néanmoins tout va bien quand
tu t'énerves ça doit pas peur un peu je
pense à moi des fois je dis juste comme
ça mais je t'ai jamais vu pour le coup
très en colère
des enfants moi ça m'arrive si je vais
dans les égoles j'engueule les enfants
j'arrive j'en prends un hasard je lui
dis non ça va oui bon allez le mecs
il y a pas de Monsieur déjà tu
m'appelles papa
qu'est-ce que tu me donnes ton goûter
allez tu n'auras pas de goûter
si tu vas dans la rue tu vas voir
quelqu'un qui marche qui fait c'est
terminé je démissionne
notre comportement rien fait c'est très
drôle ça c'est les training de la vraie
vie quoi
ça prend forme on en est alors de façade
ça c'est toujours la frustration avec
les Lego c'est que plus on avance moi on
voit de niveau de détails et tout se
passe après à l'intérieur le monde de
magique des Harry Potter marseillais
paramètres
terrible t'as toujours un truc à dire tu
vois ça
donc là la personne qui fera le montage
là tu vois tu es très fort tu oublies ce
que je voulais dire sur toi c'est un
terrible secret que vous leur révélé et
il faut bien qu'il reste jusqu'au bout
de la vidéo peut-être qu'on l'avoir quoi
bah restez jusqu'au bout et à la fin je
délivre que à ceux qui se seront abonné
bien sûr mais est-ce que tu penses qu'il
y en a qui regarde là ils sont pas
abonnés tu as quel numéro d'étape toi
oui il y a les numéros
toi tu es 36 36
[Musique]
non il me faut de l'eau parce que je
suis en pleine croissance tu veux de
l'eau je cherche
pas il me faut de l'eau je suis en
pleine croissance non ah ouais non ça
apparaît tout de suite
[Musique]
il me faut de l'eau de l'eau et bien
jadis d'ailleurs mais toi ton jadis
encore une fois
plus notre écart il compte moi c'est en
vrai j'ai assez vite de regarder la télé
que j'habitais seul d'accord je
regardais que les films que je louais en
VHS Vidéo Futur pour mon Vidéo Futur
pour moi et j'avais un combiné télé
magnétoscope ouais mais ça c'était
pratique pour le coup
tu as déjà vu les trucs ou soit c'est
qui c'est combiné qui fait ça le vidéo
club là où ils invitent des tu vois ce
vidéo club ouais c'est le vidéo club où
j'allais moi quand j'étais petit puisque
j'habitais la porte à côté est-ce que ça
t'a donné le goût et le patient du
cinéma bah en vrai ouais parce que ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que quand
j'étais petit et ben j'y allais souvent
et du coup je me suis fait pote avec les
vendeurs enfin les gens qui étaient là
comme si tu fais qu'en fait normalement
ce qui se passait avec si tu prenais un
abonnement et tu avais un nombre de
films sauf que comme moi j'y allais
souvent passer la cassette ok on fait
regarde là tu me la redescends
le nombre de films que j'ai regardé
grâce à ça
et que je faisais un peu le mec ouais
mais moi bien sûr moi je me rends les
films tout ça ils m'ont quand même filé
des trucs où je regardais des films qui
étaient très adaptés à ton âge non pas à
pas à ce point-là mais je parle en terme
de violence ou de c'est exactement ça
j'ai regardé l'exorciste frérot je
devais avoir 4 ans après j'avais
peut-être 8 ans je veux dire que la
scène où elle descend l'escalier à
l'envers traumatisé la place dans
l'autre sens elle le monde du coup
et là c'est peut-être moins traumatisant
tout à fait voilà pas mal
troisième sachet donc voilà ça c'est à
l'issue de mon deuxième sachet ça c'est
le devant attendez je vous ouvre ça vous
pouvez rentrer à l'intérieur bienvenu
alors c'est encore en travaux vous nous
excuserez
ça va faire un peu de bruit parce que je
fais mon dernier sachet de la dernière
étape qu'est-ce que tu
faisais des casquettes
et souvent des gens qui me demandent
alors toi maintenant c'est bon tu es
trop fort en casse-tête Loïc j'ai fait
ban face d'exploration tout ça tu
connais mais sinon bah non pas tant qui
ce qui qui les Lego comme les Lego c'est
méga méga kicks c'était déjà assez court
comme ça
[Musique]
aux enfants que tu vas engueuler devant
l'école
[Rires]
en train de faire cette pièce là
il faut faire la tienne quand ça se
passe comme ça ils vont là voilà
au moins on est sur quelle époque
je reviens au premier non c'était dans
le premier sac sinon
il se passe quoi là
qu'est-ce que tu as fait là tu as fait
du ça d'accord après tu as fait là
d'accord il y a du travail il y a du
robot dans cette vidéo hein
[Musique]
mais qu'est-ce que tu en penses de je
pense que c'est belle plateforme que ça
transformé paysage des plateformes
d'Internet n'est-ce pas c'est que sur
l'économie de l'attention en fait on
découvre la prochaine vidéo en
permanence et donc tout le monde se
pièce de là et je me demande ce que va
devenir vraiment la création de contenu
dans le temps ça va répondre vraiment
aux besoins de occupe mon cerveau avec
le moins d'engagement possible de ma
part tu vois puisque je ne choisis plus
la vidéo on connaît ça d'être devant
Netflix de pas savoir quoi regarder et
tout d'être devant YouTube savoir encore
regarder là on te dit quoi regarder on
te propose et c'est à switch toutes les
15 secondes et du coup je j'utilise la
plateforme et je trouve intéressante en
tant que tu trouves qu'on peut il y a
des choses qu'on peut faire dessus et
tout et en même temps une espèce de qui
est vrai que de l'économie d'attention
quoi c'est du il y a beaucoup ça part
sur du contenu pour du contenu quoi pour
ceux qui veulent percer ou pour ceux qui
en font leur métier tu es obligé de
poster tellement tu as vu des comptes
qu'on a regardé ou le mec il a envie de
faire dans la journée
et je comprends en plus qu'ils aient pas
le choix de le faire parce que la
plateforme l'impose par son
fonctionnement quoi tu vois mais c'est
ah c'est ça moi je suis en train de
faire que des petites les petites
chiques là qui vont à l'intérieur moi
pareil alors là c'est vraiment la même
chose que toi là pourquoi tu prends tout
ça
[Musique]
est-ce que tu as déjà regardé tu as bien
oui
Google Maps ah ouais moi j'utilise
quasiment que Google Maps j'aime pas
l'appli plan de c'est déjà fait le truc
si tu peux aller regarder tout tes
trajets tous les endroits que tu as
visité ah oui et ben c'est assez
impressionnant si vous voulez si vous
l'avez ou si vous l'avez pas fait je
vous invite à le faire c'est assez
impression ah mais je suis allé à dans
ou ces endroits et tu vois tu fais en
fait j'ai un peu pour la gay
bourlinguer avec ça tu bourlinguais que
spams alors qu'est-ce que ça me propose
là je vais mettre des cheminées moi mon
petit pote comme ça que ça sent la fin
je vais faire des petits lampadaires tu
sais quoi moi ça avance doucement mais
sûrement comme on dit voilà la famille
la famille
on va ta mère toujours la chaîne de
confiture
qui puisque même moi je me souviens plus
dans quelle vidéo on avait fait ça tu en
es à la page combien toi
moi j'en ai plus moi et en étape tu en
as combien moi j'en ai 123 si on
comptait deux petits objets 163 et après
tu as choisi oui tu connais des gens qui
commencent toutes leurs phrases par non
non mais ouais non d'accord on fait ça
pourquoi tu dis non ça va non
tranquille ça non mais c'est ce que je
voulais dire pas trop la douleur mais
pourquoi tu dis non
déteste tu écoutes quoi comme genre de
musique vraiment une question de bah tu
es obligé de répondre ben un peu de tout
peu de tout en fait ça dépend des
moments et puis tout le monde a cette
réponse là aussi de après moi j'ai un
truc ou des fois je suis focus sur le
même album que j'écoute en boucle mais
ça c'est moi quoi ça c'est que moi par
contre est-ce que toi tu as ça de
t'entends une chanson qui te plaît tu
vas le saignac ah oui mais je pense pas
il y a trop qu'on est beaucoup comme ça
que tu ne peux plus l'écouter ou pas ah
le petit jouet pour adulte
OK
c'est un peu satisfaisant
[Musique]
oh un peu satisfaisant faites des Lego à
deux évidemment cette vidéo n'est pas
ton saut mais on est ouvert à toute
sponsor rétroactive de la part de Lego
il a un accès dans les mains ton petit
perso ou pas
moi je fais ça
[Musique]
rapide les gens des records du monde
l'ego Lego master par exemple émission
d'accord je le sens je le sens tendu là
il veut que ça évite lui hein tu es lent
quoi bah ouais mais enlève ta grosse
main pleine de doigts
[Musique]
on a commencé il y avait rien quoi c'est
ça qui est trop satisfaisant bon voilà
c'est du one man montage
[Musique]
un peu et on va faire gagner les petits
éléments qui restent c'est Instagram
abonnez-vous
tous les mots de la terre je vois pas
très bien à quoi ça correspondant c'est
la tuile avec de la neige
forcément c'est dans l'autre sens et
donc en fait ça va s'accrocher là dedans
donc il faut y aller un peu
[Rires]
contre toi je veux on reste amis mais là
là
quoi pourquoi je le mets à l'envers je
suis débile ou quoi on va être bien salé
s'il vous plaît les frérot il s'est
passé quoi là
il y en a qui ont du mal à s'attacher
et lui là d'accord continue je te fais
des petits bails
en vrai c'est mal foutu
de toi et les toituriers pourquoi ils
font des toits d'après toi
merci
[Musique]
ça nous fera notre point de rêve pour
les autres vidéos si on continue à en
faire d'après
14h
pour la vie attends mais ils ont pas
tourné tu as oublié de mettre des trucs
sur ton toit mon gars
voilà ça c'est bien c'est pour
l'isolation
je sais que c'est un truc préféré
ah j'aime bien c'est joli hein ah ouais
ouais j'avais une anecdote
une fois j'étais sur une trottinette
et un mec qui m'a mis une claque et il a
réussi à te mettre un état de sidération
on parle de la sidération mentale c'est
ça
je m'y attendais tellement pas qu'il me
dit je m'attendais que ça parte un peu
en embrouille un peu hop on y va et même
une claque oh les claque si pire truc ça
fait tu sais c'est
encore un coup de poing ok métro
j'arrête de me claquer en fait là parce
que je m'auto énerve pas de moi
je te laisse pour la fin tu as tes
petits personnages je te laisse les
mettre en scène comme tu veux ou tu veux
là à l'intérieur ils font leurs petites
affaires alors ah c'est fini moi
manipulé aujourd'hui
et elle c'est la tenancier maintenant
siège c'est de toute beauté c'est de
toute beauté
deux heures 844 pièces donc quand on va
s'en acheter un de 4,5000 pièces on aura
pour plus de 2h mais là moi c'était la
première fois que je le faisais de
brancher des Lego on leur fait voir ou
pas bah bien sûr c'est maintenant
[Musique]
c'était notre première vidéo LEGO et
peut-être ma dernière il y a plus de
chance que ce soit celle que on est sur
quelle chaîne la principale ou la
seconde guerre dans les deux cas
abonnez-vous là où vous êtes dites nous
si ça vous dit moi je relèverais bien
des gros challenges je vous dis que j'ai
repéré la voiture Ghostbusters